la tendance prend de l'ampleur et
dérangent les vidéos de comptes anonymes
vu par des milliers d'abonnés avec un
titre commençant par le mot j'expose
suivi d'une vidéo montrant par exemple
la personne la plus de watts de l'école
ou encore la fille qui consomment à 13
ans d'autres titres vont plus loin et
identifie les cols de l'élève visé c'est
de la méchanceté gratuitement puis c'est
chiant le stop et un an voir si t'as pas
l'autorisation de la personne pauvre
procès ça fasse ses preuves
et toutes les vidéos contiennent la même
trame sonore
celle de ce rappeur qui ont des plans
d'utilisation depuis sa côte d'ivoire
natale
au moins un minimum de respect pour
[Musique]
ce n'est pas par où commencer plusieurs
ont dénoncé ces publications
cette future enseignante le fait sur
techt sa légende à travers
signaler c'est compliqué il faut
absolument que ça s'arrête parce que
c'est de l'intimidation mis à grande
portée
tout le monde est capable d'avoir accès
à ces choses là puis à l'époque
l'intimidation je pense que ça
s'arrêtait quand les gens rentrent chez
eux soit mais leur talent et pour lui
même le soir la tendance s'est répandue
rapidement elle a débuté par les vidéos
de deux utilisatrices française puis
elle s'est installée au québec la
semaine dernière de quelle façon
intervenir auprès des élèves ciblés les
interroger sur nos pratiques anti dl
conscience de ce que la plateforme une
plateforme comme tictoc va faire de leur
publication est-ce que ils comprennent
ce que ça peut provoquer chez les
personnes qui mettent en scène alors
quand c'est positif drôle c'est une
chose quand ça peut devenir négatif et
du harcèlement c'en est une autre c'est
lente et tables de nombreux cantons ont
été supprimés dans les derniers jours
ici mélissa françois reds au canada
montréal